right now youtube shorts for everybody  here should be their number one  obsession so being great at youtube  shorts is a something i highly recommend  lots of virality but youtube has  something which is search so when you  make it you title it it can go viral but  then it sits on the number two search  engine in the world which is youtube if  i'm making video of like how to taste  riesling is something people might  search does all white wine have to be  cold all these are things that people  would search but i still might make a  garyvee video in front of it i can make  it entertaining and informative but the  metadata underneath is more search based  which makes it more evergreen long-term  youtube shorts that you should focus on